yesterday we had a shooting contest
McLovin against Doug Gottlieb and was
very tense it was 10 free throws and
then it went into sudden death and then
McLovin pulled out the victory and some
people were watching this apparently
Mike Penberthy he's the Lakers shooting
coach and he stopped by today he just
wanted to see the form of our shooters
here on the roster Mike and what did you
think first of all yesterday with the
showdown between Doug Gottlieb and
McLovin yeah it was tense I mean there
was some there was some definite some
nerves there and and that's a big part
of shooting has actually been able to
control your nerves but when you guys
you're trying to tell how do you teach
confidence well you have to practice I
mean your confidence comes from practice
some guys have to practice more than
others and that that just takes a lot
more work but you have to put a lot of
time and effort in to be a great shooter
bottom line but we've seen guys who go
to the free-throw line and get into
their own head like Lonzo ball who's not
with the Lakers anymore but you're
shooting just over 40 percent from the
free-throw line
that's almost him you're almost trying
to miss if you're gonna shoot 41 percent
yeah I meant I played with Shaq I
remember Shaq going to the line at
practice and he would make nine out of
10 10 out of 10 and then he would get to
the free-throw line sometimes during the
games and sometimes you get too
technical and you're thinking you start
thinking about your elbow or your hands
or what you're supposed to be looking at
so some guys who are actually just just
get up there and don't care and shoot it
right away they intend to make more
shots because they just don't think
other guys are I just have bad form I
would say a lot of guys in league
nowadays are younger these younger
generation guys just kind of get up and
shoot it and I think they need to think
a little more about their form so it
depends on who you are and what you got
going but you also get into a rhythm too
you get into comfort zones there what is
your role as the shooting coach of the
Lakers
well it's there's a lot of facets to it
there's a lot I mean obviously there's
there's 12 players were working with
there I'll shoot the ball differently
all of them have different shot attempts
that they get per game so some guys if
they who shoot you know five or six
times per game it's important for them
to be making those shots other guys who
take 2530 shots a game it's more about
shot selection maybe finding a rhythm
maybe
getting to the line more often so
helping guys understand their roles and
then and then to just be able to make
shots it that comes down to shot
selection knowing our offense
understanding where your shots are gonna
come from and then there may be times
when maybe their form or maybe their
technique or maybe their rhythm is off
and you can go through some some things
some some drills to help them find that
during the season how comfortable are
you walking up to Chara and LeBron and
going you know I I see something with
your shot yeah I mean it takes time to
build trust I mean obviously the
superstar he's he's one of the greatest
players ever lived so I I don't no
problem talking about shooting at all
and he's just score yeah not necessarily
a shooter yeah and and being a score you
know finding your rhythm at the
free-throw line is really important
because some some nights you may not
feel it and I think you need to fall in
love with getting to the line you need
to want to get to the line to find your
rhythm there are some things and
technically that you can help with with
everybody I think everybody can become a
better shooter I think as you get older
you actually improving your skills you
got lettuce isn't may decline but your
your skill set may improve I mean you're
still a really good shooter so there are
guys who can still shoot it as they get
older in fact they get better at it Kyle
Korver is a great example as he gets
older he I think he gets better as a
shooter so I think LeBron can still
improve as a shooter and yeah I don't
have any problem talking with him about
that all but also and by the way am i a
really good shooter oh yeah yeah or
great shoes yeah the word was like the
word was pure when I was that is true
that was my nickname in high school
it was pure that that is pure l I think
is what it was in high school
well I also like if I said your life's
on the line and somebody's gonna take a
shot to save your life yeah you might
not pick the best shooter but you might
pick the most clutch gun yeah so anybody
all-time besides you of course yeah and
me clutch shooter yeah that you're gonna
take with your life on the line Larry
Bird
no doubt no doubt yeah greatest clutch
shooter of all time I think so and I
think there are tons of categories that
fit different types of shooters catch
and shoot or off the dribble or whatever
but in terms of clutch shooting if I'm
gonna bet my life on it I'm throwing
Larry Bird the ball even if through
three-point range
oh yeah yeah not Ray Allen Steph Curry
no no
I'm betting my life on Thrones labor
have you ever critiqued somebody who's a
would-be appear to us to be a great
shooter appear to you meaning yeah like
we would go boy you can't say anything
negative about Steph Curry or klay
Thompson yeah I mean I think I can help
all those guys become better shooters
there's always somewhere you can improve
in whether it be balance or shot
selection or or you may be a how low you
are getting into your shot or how you
catch the ball so there's always there's
always room for improvement even with
guys like klay Thompson and Steph Curry
but I think they work so hard and they
know their shot so well that they they
would actually probably embrace it I've
worked with Kyle Korver and he was
willing a hundred percent to listen to
everything I said which was incredible
and he's one of the great shooters ever
Ray Allen's pretty good he's high on
that list right he came into our man
cave and I seeked his shot I did well it
didn't go over well with him but I don't
know he had the ball on the palm of his
hand a little bit yeah and I like more
fingertip control then you let it sit on
that yeah I mean Ray could have been a
great shooter if you'd listened to me a
long time ago can you see where that
might be an issue if I think the balls
on the palm your handle yeah I don't
think palms I think it's the worst place
to have the ball yeah there's too many
options you have five fingers you don't
want them going off all yeah I think you
should come off of these two if a parent
is listening now and the advice that you
would give to the parent or drill what
do you do because I've said before there
are a few things that I always tell kids
you know don't just shoot if you're
going to work out then work out and make
it feel like a game situation because
nobody's just gonna let you walk you
know 14 feet out and shoot jumpers so
work on these things off the dribble
left and right get it up as quick as
possible but the one drill that you
would say to parents this is what your
kids need to work on well every great
shooter has great backspin I mean you
can go back the test time there's there
haven't been any great shooters that
have had knuckle balls so the backspin
is is everything as it pertains to
shooting in terms of that's that's the
result of what you're doing
so I would say in terms of evaluating
your shot if you're if your child
doesn't have backspin he needs to have
backspin when he shoots it that can
become from a thumb or from come off the
wrong hand or whatever but like early on
if you don't fix that problem later on
you're gonna have issues so backspin and
how the ball comes off your fingers and
then I just tell kids all the time shoot
a high and swish it I mean try to swish
every shot you take why shoot the ball
if you're not trying to swish it what
would you do with Ben Simmons well I
mean beds I mean he's an issue player
but I don't want you to get in trouble
here yeah yeah no and I won't I mean
Ben's that kind of guy okay I would love
to work with you know what you do with a
player like Ben Simms
yeah well he's actually really good
going right you know there's been a
debate about that I like what he should
do right let's see right-hander left I
don't know actually finishes right he's
amazing going to his right like he's
probably he probably is more comfortable
going to his right yeah so I don't
actually know what Cheney is but that
would be a question I would ask him and
I would try to take him back to when he
was younger I mean I think all of us
shot the ball really good when we were
13 12 and then you know you get older
and something happens in a shoot maybe
somebody tells you hey you gotta change
your form or you gotta shoot in a
certain way and then you get outside of
what's natural I would take him back to
where or a guy like him back to where
he's just more natural and where things
feel easier to do a shooting is not that
hard when you take it back to where you
were younger and use your body more use
your legs more when you shoot I also
tell kids that you know get close to the
hoop and just work on follow-through so
you're not struggling to get it up
because kid Steph Curry has changed
basketball absolutely and every kid
identifies with Steph Curry because he
looks like he's a kid and they all want
to shoot three-pointers right yeah he'll
have a greater impact on the game than
Michael Jordan will or any other player
in history because they changed the
style of basketball and he opened up
everybody's eyes that you could do this
yeah and just to get that form down mhm
because we start off with shooting off
our hip mm-hmm and until you get to that
point where you're strong enough and
that's why I we say start close and just
to get the feel of what it's supposed to
be like and then as you start to creep
out a little bit more
and a little bit more range to it yeah I
I think you're right Steph Curry's
changed the entire culture of basketball
more people can do what he did I
couldn't do what Michael Jordan did but
I can relate to Steph Curry a lot more
would you like for me to show I mean if
you want me to go to Laker practice like
a consultant do you mind
i'ma know you're busy yeah well here's
the thing the Clippers have already
asked mmm
but I'm gonna be loyal to you my because
the Clippers shooting coaches in here
but you're here but if you want to tell
Jeannie if you want me to do a dry but
who who do you want me to work with yeah
come by yep spent some time with Anthony
he's somebody I've known previously he's
you know he's he's pretty good yeah you
what he could use you know you were in
New Orleans last year yeah so you were
the shooting coach last year yep last
couple years
yep Anthony's got a nice nice touch
there yeah he's pretty good yeah I I
knew a couple years ago he was working
on extending and then you know but he
was a smaller player had point guard
skills and then grew had this growth
spurt yeah unique in his in his growth
as a player to start it like that I mean
I'd love to have gotten nine inches all
right we got Phillip Rivers coming up
but McLovin wanted to shoot you with
free throws I did wait why so best of
ten yeah yeah I did show camp yeah I
have to go in the water if I lose this
time it's up to you Mike oh no I'm gonna
ask you again Mike what do you think are
you capable of doing that mclovin yeah I
mean I took down Gottlieb the all-time
assist leader now a three-point shooter
who are you gonna bring out in X's Steph
Curry klay Thompson coming tomorrow Mike
almost made 40% of his three-point shots
I think in your NBA career yeah I made a
few yeah and then you got to play with
with Shaq and Kobe and yeah and Phil
Jackson was coach was a great run what's
your favorite story that you always tell
that check I was walking to practice
from the from the hotel shaq pulled up
next to me asked me what I was doing
this
about two weeks in the camp he says what
are you doing I scare me to death and I
said I'm just going to practice he says
my teammates don't practice my teammates
don't walk you need a car and my wife
you know I had one car I was you know
barely making it and I said yeah yeah he
goes into his glove compartment he
throws me a wad of cash he says go buy a
car I said how much money are we talking
about
I don't know hit me like a softball I
was like knock knock the wind out of me
you know there was just one just one
little wad you know and bang me right in
the chest so there's a million stories
like that but one of the most gracious
people on earth and over under five
grand that he sent you it they over for
sure over under ten grand
hit me pretty hard that's a great story
a lot of those great guy yeah it's great
to see you Mike I know that you listen
to the show and we appreciate that good
luck this year as the shooting coach for
the Lakers Mike Penberthy and stick
around because you're gonna take on
McLovin in about 15 minutes from now if
you're capable of doing okay I'm ready
I'm off the IR okay two shooting contest
McLovin took down Doug Gottlieb
yesterday and now Mike 10 murthy the
Lakers shooting coaches here what do I
got but if I squeeze off ten okay
no doubt about that one I can soft run
rebel hey there's backroom when it
rebounds back to all I hope you know
you've really made it but I tried on how
I tried to countermand this is if I hit
the rim Dan short I was a myth just
short
I think it's which oh yeah he shoots at
least 90% it just alleged something by
the way I don't know I think this is ten
seven I love this
a tie is a win from a clubbing a tie how
here we go first away right night water
it was short arm in that one I should
have a professional I should be on a big
the club has got good for he does
actually he's got a nice tight little
nervous he didn't wait yesterday you
know he laid on the front rim a couple
times nice yeah I'm totally nervous we
have watching Mikey said before it's all
instrumental none of us have any ability
that's all right I gotta go in the water
[Laughter]
second five seconds watch your boy
[Laughter]
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]